[Music]
imagine
a white picket fence around a white
house with a white driveway and
a white car and it's not just your house
that's white
it's also the road sidewalks and
every single building everything's white
this is mad it looks boring and sterile
but
it could be the future and it could
help save our world
how much paint would you need
why would your electricity bill be lower
and why would white paint fight
climate change this
is what if and here's what would happen
if we painted the earth white
the human race is facing a huge threat
a mass extinction of plants and animals
dwindling food and extreme weather
awaits us
if we don't stop the increasing heat
from climate change
and if we let the global temperature
rise by just
six degrees we're toast
there are tons of ideas out there about
how to stop the rising temperatures
one idea is painting roofs roads and
other surfaces with white paint
sunlight contains three different types
of light
visible infrared and uv light
when visible light hits a surface that
energy
is either absorbed or reflected
the fraction of light that is reflected
by a surface
is called albedo a high albedo
means that a surface reflects a lot of
light
while a low albedo means that a surface
absorbs more light
dark asphalt roads have a low albedo
so they absorb a lot of light that's why
they get so hot in the summertime
snow has a high albedo and reflects
95 of solar radiation
currently the earth has an albedo of
30 percent so the surface of the earth
absorbs
plenty of sunlight which contributes to
rising temperatures
and climate change lowers earth's albedo
it's a vicious cycle that goes like this
the earth gets hotter which melts ice
caps
because there's less snow less light is
reflected back into space
and the earth's albedo becomes lower so
earth absorbs more sunlight and heat
which increases earth's temperature
and melts more ice caps but
we can slow this warming cycle
painting the earth white would
significantly
increase its albedo and if the earth's
albedo
increases it would reflect more visible
light
back into space which would cool surface
temperatures
if you've lived through a heat wave
you'd likely appreciate
cooler temperatures and we're not
talking about
using just any white paint we'd need to
use
a special paint that was recently
developed
this paint reflects 95.5 percent of
incoming light
and it could cool surface temperatures
up to 1.7 degrees
lower than the surrounding air
temperature we'd need
about 60 000 swimming pools worth of
this stuff to
cover all the urban areas on earth we'd
coat
roofs roads and pavement in this paint
raising the albedo of urban areas by 10
percent
if we painted everything tomorrow by the
year 2300
we'd lower global temperatures by up to
0.07 degrees
now that might not sound like a lot but
it would be like offsetting the
emissions of
all the cars in the world for the next
20 to 30 years
it would take a couple of hundred years
for this temperature decrease to happen
but
there are some immediate effects
the white paint would decrease the urban
heat island effect so you wouldn't have
to run your air conditioner as much
during the summer
you could end up saving as much as 50
dollars a month on cooling costs
now the downside of the white paint is
all that
glare you'd want to buy a good pair of
sunglasses to protect your eyes from the
blinding light
but just painting the earth white won't
solve our climate crisis we'd still have
to
grapple with the greenhouse gas effect
as the amounts of carbon dioxide and
methane in our atmosphere
increase they create a blanket of gases
that
trap infrared radiation this
will continue to warm our planet even
with our new paint job
so although painting the earth white or
at least our roads and roofs
could help mitigate rising temperatures
it would have to be one small part of a
larger plan
to geo-engineer the earth
but that's a story for another
what if
you